tarzan
oh i see
oh i see
tarzan
oh i see
no no no no
i'm jane
no no no no
i'm jane
no no
jane
tarzan
jane
jane
exactly
let's learn english with the disney
classic tarzan
but before we start every single week we
release new lessons like this one to
help you to understand fast speaking
natives without getting lost without
missing the jokes and without subtitles
so hit that subscribe button and the
bell down below now so that you don't
miss a single new lesson
i'll handle this guys okay
listen buddy come here we got a tiny
little itsy bitsy problem here okay
personally i'd love to hang out with you
you know i would but the guys
they need a little convincing you know
okay what am i gonna do do what do you
gotta do
oh it's still stupid what well
you gotta uh you gotta go get a hair
a hair yeah a hair uh-huh
[Music]
an elephant hair
an elephant hair like i said it's stupid
right listen take it from me go home
okay who needs this aggravation you know
i'm probably gonna leave soon myself you
go i'll catch up all right
you see leave it to me i told you
[Applause]
[Music]
i'll handle this guys okay
turk is telling her friends that she
will deal with tarzan since her friends
don't look very excited to spend time
with him you can say i'll handle this
when you mean that you will take care of
a delicate situation check out this
example
look at your control panel
oh
a 5
13.
i'll handle it
[Music]
that's got it
we got a tiny little itsy bitsy problem
here okay
turk is emphasizing how small the
problem is by saying tiny little itsy
bitsy something tiny is extremely small
itsy bitsy is an informal way to also
say that something is very small in fact
there's a popular nursery rhyme called
the itsy bitsy spider a nursery rhyme is
a kids song here's an example itsy bitsy
spider went up the water spout
down came the rain
and washed the spider out
personally i'd love to hang out with you
you know i would the phrasal verb to
hang out with someone means to spend
time with someone usually in order to do
fun things together this phrasal verb is
commonly used among friends also notice
that it doesn't really matter where you
are with your friends if you hang out
you spend time together regardless if it
is at home or someplace else
the takamoto bowl that's where scoob and
shaggy hang out oh no
okay what am i gonna do notice the
connected speech patterns here the d in
the auxiliary verb do is pronounced with
a flap sound duh we can hear the same
sound in the word gotta the full version
of this word would be got to but as you
can see two reduces to uh the sound so
we hear what i gotta do then turk
responds with the same sounds what do
you gotta do listen again
okay what do i gotta do do what do you
gotta do
well
you gotta uh you gotta go get a hat
again we can hear the word gada here but
notice that the article a after the verb
get has the same sound so get a becomes
geta so we hear you gotta go get a hair
let's practice this one together repeat
after me
you gotta
you gotta
you gotta go
you gotta go
you gotta go get up
you gotta go get her
you gotta go get a hair
you gotta go get a hair
so he's calling from rome i could do
that
just gotta go to rome
isn't it frustrating when you're
watching tv series or a movie or you're
listening to a song and you can't
understand what was said usually this is
not because the person is speaking too
fast rather it is because you are not
used to how natives reduce
cut and connect our words together
however you can learn it so that you can
understand natives no matter how fast we
speak and the most fun way to do this is
with our fluent with friends course in
this course you will learn all of the
most common aspects of connected speech
so that you can confidently understand
natives and even improve your
pronunciation so you can give it a try
now for free with our three part master
class what are you waiting for just
click up here or down the description
below to sign up now
listen take it from me
this is a great phrase if you say to
someone take it from me you are telling
the person to listen to what you have to
say this phrase is usually used when
giving someone a piece of advice
and take it from me boss you are going
to have one satisfied princess man let's
face it you are a lot easier on the eyes
who needs this aggravation you know
aggravation is a noun that means trouble
or difficulty when turk says this to
tarzan she means who needs to go through
all this trouble it's still green
they headed north two hours ago
it's still green they headed north two
hours ago
you don't need this aggravation
give me the baby i can track humans down
a lot faster than you can
you'll go i'll catch up all right
in this context to catch up means you go
first and i'll follow you soon the
question catch up can also be used when
you talk to someone who you haven't
talked to in a while so you get together
to catch up in other words to hear each
other's news
we'll uh we'll catch up okay sure i'm so
proud of you
both of you
stay back
don't come in don't come any closer
please don't
what are you doing
[Laughter]
no get off get out get get off
it serves you right now you stay away
from me like a very good wild man
you stay
i'm warning you my father won't take it
to you no that's now that's close enough
how dare
what
[Music]
don't come in don't come any closer
there's nothing particularly
sophisticated about this sentence but
this is just a great way to warn someone
to stay back and keep distance from you
we're not doing this together we're not
doing it at all say goodbye to your
tickets
as we can see in this scene tarzan is
touching jane's foot which makes her
laugh if something tickles it makes you
feel a slightly uncomfortable physical
feeling that makes you want to laugh
honey stop that tickles
no get off get out get get off since
tarzan has lived in the jungle all his
life he's never met another human being
before obviously he's very interested in
jane even to the point of getting too
close to her this is an interesting
phrasal verb if you tell someone to get
off in this context it means the person
is invading your personal space by
standing too close to you and you want
the person to stay back
that's okay frank yeah we'll have some
fun with them don't let them impale me
please i want to live get off me
come on you're making a
it's up to right jane ends up kicking
tarzan's face because he was tickling
her foot and starting to act
inappropriately the phrase it serves you
right is used when someone does
something to you that you don't like
then suffer some sort of punishment as a
result in other words the person gets
what he or she deserves
[Laughter]
well serves you right spoiling people's
best dreams
yes i know it's a lovely morning but
it was a lovely dream too
my father wouldn't take it to you jane
is telling tarzan her father won't
accept or like him if you take kindly to
someone you accept or approve of that
person
if someone does something to upset you
and it is something that shocks you you
can use this explanation if we were to
rephrase this question it would look
something like this how did you have the
courage to do this how did you have the
guts to do this remember that this is a
disapproving phrase
your majesty i am prince aliyah obama
just let her meet me i will win your
daughter how dare you
all of you standing around deciding my
future
i am not a prize to be one
[Music]
i'll handle this guys okay
listen buddy come here we got a tiny
little itsy bitsy problem here okay
personally i'd love to hang out with you
you know i would but the guys
they need a little convincing you know
okay what do i gotta do what do you
gotta do
oh it's still stupid what
well
you gotta uh you gotta go get a hair
a hair yeah uh yeah
an elephant hair
an elephant hair like i said it's stupid
right listen take it from me go home
okay
fill in the blanks to form a word that
means trouble or difficulty
needs this aggravation you know i'm
probably gonna leave soon myself you'll
go i'll catch up all right
you see leave it to me i told you
[Applause]
[Music]
stay back
don't come in don't come any closer
please don't
what are you doing
[Laughter]
after kicking tarzan in the face what
phrase did jane use to express that
tarzan got what he deserved
it serves you right now you stay away
from me like a very good wild man
you stay
i'm warning you
fill in the gap with the correct form of
the word in brackets
my father wouldn't take guidance to you
no that's now that's close enough
how day
[Music]
want to improve your english speaking
then check out this lesson where you can
practice your speaking with case let's
check it out here you go
i feel exactly the same way i like to
learn new recipes especially dishes from
other countries
do you enjoy cooking
[Music]
i know right maybe next time you come
over we can whip up a meal together
that was absolutely fantastic
now we'll switch lines you'll start and
i'll respond
okay let's go